[Music]
there are places out there you can't
find on any map
they're not gone
they're just lost
hey kid a little young for a bartender
aren't you a little old for prom aren't
you
falling all around
everything in here why the map this path
to ferdinand magellan took the sale
around the world you know your history
it's the biggest treasure that's never
been found 5 billion easy
to go i think you're here because you're
your brother well you know my brother's
sick
sally doesn't have any friends i should
know i'm one of them
[Music]
you're a collector well i dabble i don't
know
my family has been looking for this
person for a very long time so much
blood
i'm pretty sure he's just threatening to
kill me but don't touch your ear like
that you look like an idiot
you have no idea who you partnered with
i've been dreaming about this stuff
since i was a kid my brother's saying
that one final clue
guess i'll keep
oh my god i should never come out to
believe in that big boys you're about to
get a proper scottish welcome
what
oh crap
exclusively in movie theaters
[Music]
you